el caso Roe vs Wade
1973 que permitió la despenalización del
aborto en Estados Unidos podría tener
las horas contadas
este miércoles empezaron los argumentos
de los jueces de la Corte Suprema
estudian la petición del estado de
Mississippi que solicita reducir el
derecho al aborto a las 15 semanas de
gestación y sin hacer excepciones en
caso de incesto o violación
actualmente está entre 23 y 24 semanas
es el momento considerado de viabilidad
del feto fuera del vientre materno el
presidente de la Corte insinúo
suposición
el problema es que las mujeres deberían
tener la opción de interrumpir su
embarazo eso significa que hay un
momento en el que han tenido la
oportunidad justa de elegir porque 15
semanas tendrían que ser inapropiada
de los nueve magistrados 6 son
conservadores después de que trames
cogiese A3 la jueza liberal Sonia
Sotomayor expreso preocupación por la
legitimidad de la Corte en caso de
derogar la ley
si la gente
como vamos a sobrevivir cómo sobrevivir
al tribunal
[Música]
quiero que necesitaba creo que van a ver
a miles de personas acá porque hay mucho
en juego es el mayor desafío en décadas
y nuestros derechos los reproductivos
están en juego y contrarios a la
interrupción
de
ellos podrían restringir el aborto con
medidas más drásticas que las de
Mississippi